- I think we, as I was
saying a few minutes ago,
I think we have
to go on offense.
So often, Republicans
are so afraid to lean in
and take the offensive position.
And we sort of apologize many
times for being conservative.
And we shouldn't allow the left
to, one, define
us or demonize us.
And we have allowed
that for far too long.
We have to stand up
and start pushing back.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin.
And joining me today
is the 47th governor
of the great state of Arkansas.
Governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so
much for having me.
It's great to finally
get to connect
and be part of your show.
- Yeah, thanks, governor.
You know, we've bumped into
each other a couple times,
since you've been governor,
before you were governor,
when you were press secretary,
I think even before that,
but finally making this happen.
So we've got about a half hour,
I kind of wanna talk
about everything.
Can you give everybody just,
like, maybe the minute bio
before all of politics and
then we'll go from there.
- Well, I've been in
politics for a long time.
So my bio before that
isn't super long,
but I've spent a lot more
time behind the scenes
than I ever did in
front of the camera.
And so, I was a political
strategist and operative,
ran campaigns all
over the country,
sort of accidentally
became the press secretary
for Donald Trump.
Amazing job, great opportunity.
Loved my two and a
half years there.
Grew up with a dad who was
obviously very involved
in politics,
still one of the longest
serving governors of the state.
And, you know, loved
being able to watch
what he was able to accomplish,
the way he was able to
impact direct change
on people's lives.
Didn't necessarily see
myself running for office
until not too long ago,
but really wanted to
continue in public service
after my time at
the White House.
Moved back home to Arkansas
and hit the ground running,
ran for governor, and spent two
years on the campaign trail,
won in November, and we
haven't slowed down since.
And it's been probably the
most amazing, and difficult,
but also rewarding job I
think I could possibly have.
- Yeah, and you guys are
getting a ton of stuff done
that I wanna focus
on for most of this,
your dad obviously
being Mike Huckabee,
but let's talk about the press
secretary part under Trump
for just a couple of minutes,
because I think
that's where probably
most people originally
know you from.
You did that for a while.
It was obviously crazy
'cause the media's
coming after you guys, you
know, like gangbusters.
You got out before
Covid, so your timing,
how do you feel about your
timing of that whole situation?
- You know, I got pretty
lucky on the timing,
but not to say we didn't have
our fair share of controversy
during my two and a half years
when I was the press secretary.
But it's probably the most
difficult, high stakes jobs
in all of government,
but it's also one of the
most amazing opportunity.
I was honored that the president
was willing to take
a chance on me.
And even on the worst days,
I really loved every
minute of the job.
I got to work with some
of the most amazing people
I've ever encountered,
and I'm thankful for the
time I got to spend there.
- When you watch, if you watch
any of these press
conferences now,
first with Psaki and now
it's Jean Karine Pierre,
and the difference
in tenor and tone
of the questions they get,
and, you know, my line
on Psaki was the woman
simply cannot say anything true.
If you asked her
her favorite number,
she would say blue.
And Karine
Jean-Pierre seems like
an even almost exaggerated
version of that.
Are you jealous in a way
or can you even believe
that it's the same room
that you guys were just getting
grilled on relentlessly?
- You know, it's hard to believe
that it is the same place
because when we would
walk into the room,
you could feel, like,
the visceral anger
a lot of times coming
off of the crowd.
And what a lot of
people don't know
is that that room is
actually really small,
and they pack 100, 150
people into this tiny space
just so they can yell
angry questions at you.
And it is a totally completely
different atmosphere
in this administration.
And, you know, I wish we got
some of the easy questions
that they got.
At the same time, I sort
of feel sorry for them
because we actually had
a good story to tell.
We had so many successes
in the Trump Presidency,
and during that time, that
I had good things to go out
and sell and talk to the
American people about.
They certainly don't have
that under Joe Biden.
Everything they seem to
touch, they screw up.
And so, they have a much,
much harder job than I did
because at least we had
good things to talk about.
- How complex does it make it
that the federal government
is screwing up so many things?
Like, do you feel like
you can accomplish
most of the things you
wanna accomplish as governor
or obviously you can't
control everything
related to the value of the
dollar and supply chain,
things like that?
- You know, there
are certainly things
that they're doing
that we can't fix
and can't do a lot about,
but there are so many places
where we have the ability
to directly impact our states.
And you're seeing a lot of
Republican governors step up
and push back against
the crazy stuff
coming out of Washington
and the overreach of
the federal government,
and frankly, take matters
into our own hands.
If they're not gonna
secure the border,
we're gonna crack down on drugs
and things coming across
the border in our states,
making sure that we're
doing what we can
where the federal government
is dropping the ball.
We focused heavily on education,
criminal justice reform,
tax cuts,
so that we are helping
the people in our states,
because we know we can't
count on anything meaningful
coming out of Washington.
- Yeah, you know,
I've asked this
to a couple of red
state governors.
Like, do you feel that
there is an alliance
of red states right now that
basically is coming together
to solve some of
the things simply
that the federal
government will not do?
I saw you last time, I think
maybe two or three months ago,
at a Florida blueprint event.
There were a bunch of other
red state governors there,
and it seemed like, all
right, if Biden won't do it,
we're gonna have
to do this stuff.
I mean, Arkansas isn't
supposed to have to deal
with the border.
- Absolutely.
I think there's such a
greater sense of camaraderie
among Republican governors.
We're not in direct
competition with each other.
There's a great sense of shared
practice, best practices.
If I can do something here
and implement a program
that really works,
let me share that with
other states and vice versa.
There are other things
we've seen states do
and do really well and
wanna replicate that here.
And other republican governors
have been very willing
to help and work together.
And when you have
that kind of coalition
of conservative governors,
it gives us a lot more strength
to push back on the
federal government.
- What should we know about
Arkansas that we don't know?
I mean, the country doesn't
talk about Arkansas that much.
We know Bill Clinton
came from Arkansas,
we know your dad
we know you're down in Arkansas,
but it's not talked about,
say, in the way that California
or Florida might be these days.
- We're glad never to
be talked about the way
that California is,
to be clear, Dave.
- Oh, well, yeah, yeah.
- So we don't wanna be
on the same page as them.
- Fair, fair.
- In fact,
Arkansas is one of the states
that people from California
are moving to.
One of the largest
numbers of people
that are coming into our state,
I think we're the seventh
largest influx of people
from California
over the last year.
Nearly 10,000 people have left
there to come to Arkansas.
We have an amazing
story to tell.
I say all the time that
I'm the chief salesperson
for Arkansas.
We have some of the
most beautiful landscape
anywhere in the country,
great quality of life.
We're making significant
changes in progress
when it comes to a
strong education system.
We're one of the first states
that will have
universal school choice
over the next couple of years
as we phase that in
based on legislation
that we passed here just in
the last couple of months.
We are looking at all
the things that we can do
to make Arkansas the
best place to live,
to work, and to raise a family.
And I think we've
made significant
progress on that front
in just the last 100 days.
I also would tell people,
please don't judge
us by Bill Clinton.
We have a lot better things
coming out of
Arkansas than that.
- How do you make sure that
that influx of new people
votes the right
way and make sure
that they don't import
obviously the stuff
that they were fleeing in Cali.
- We tell 'em all the time,
every place I went when I was
campaigning across Arkansas,
I went to all 75
counties in our state
and held events in almost
every single place we went,
we would meet people that
came from other places,
largely California,
Oregon, Washington,
I would always remind them,
don't forget why you left
those places and came here.
Don't try to change us, just
enjoy the Southern hospitality.
And I think most of those
people were so happy
to get away from the craziness
coming from the coast
that they're embracing
all things Arkansas
all the time here.
- So you mentioned the
school choice thing.
That was one of the things
I really wanna focus
with you on because I
do think it's the future
of education in America.
You guys were one of, I think,
the first four or five states
to go with school choice.
What was your calculation there?
I mean, were Arkansas
schools being wokeified
the way that we see
so many other states?
That seems odd that it would
be happening in Arkansas,
but that obviously was at
least part of it, right?
- There's certainly
pieces of that.
And our goal is to make
sure that the crazy wokeness
never sees the
light of day here.
I'm not saying we don't have
instances, we certainly do,
but that's not
necessarily the norm.
But we wanna make sure it
doesn't become that way.
We also know that
what works in Iowa,
and Montana, and Texas may
not be what works here.
And the same thing, just
within our small state,
what works in one
corner of the state
may not work in another.
So we wanna provide
flexibility so that students
are getting the
education that they need,
and frankly, the education
that they deserve.
We wanna empower parents to
make the best decisions possible
about what and how their
kids can best be educated.
So we're putting the power
back into the hands of parents
instead of the other way.
I say all the time,
it's very simple,
when people ask me
what's the difference
between a Democrat
and a Republican, to
me, it's very easy.
If you want somebody to
make decisions for you
and you want that to
be the government,
then you're a Democrat.
If you wanna empower individuals
and you wanna make
your own decisions,
then you're a Republican.
And that's exactly
what we're doing.
We're putting power back
into the hands of the people
instead of letting
the government
dictate the rules of the game.
- Can you explain
how that philosophy
actually is reflective
of school choice?
'Cause to me, school choice
is such a winning argument
for Republicans for the
reasons that you just laid out.
But can you actually talk about,
like, what it actually means?
Okay, you have school choice,
like, what does
that actually mean?
- I think there's
a couple things.
For us, it means
that you can choose
whether it's another
public school
somewhere in your area
or around this state.
If it's a private school,
if it's homeschool,
if it's a parochial school,
if it's charter school,
you get to decide
what is the best place
that my child can go
and get the education
that best fits their needs.
I'm a mom, I have three kids,
and I can tell you
all three of my kids
are completely different and
they need different things.
So allowing me the opportunity
to tailor their education
to fit what is best gonna put
them on the path to success
is what we're trying
to implement here.
So the funding that we
give for each student
will actually
follow the student,
whether that is, again, a
homeschool, or a charter school,
another public school,
or a private school,
the parent has the
power to decide.
- What would you
say to the people
on the other side of the
argument who would say,
well, in essence, this will
just sort of disassemble
public school teaching,
and there won't be kind
of any standards anymore,
and everyone will be
learning different things?
- Well, we still
have a state standard
that you have to meet.
For a private school, you
get to opt into this program,
so it's not forced.
However, I think
the question isn't,
how does this impact
public schools?
I think the question would be,
why are people leaving
in the first place?
It's because you're not meeting
the needs of the students.
And so, I think that Republicans
have so often been on the
defensive side of this.
And we've gotta flip the script,
we've gotta go on offense.
We have the moral
high ground here.
We are trying to make
sure that every student,
no matter what their income,
what their background,
race, color, or creed,
is getting the best
education possible.
And we're putting that power
into the hands of parents.
And we're putting kids
onto a pathway of success
instead of condemning them
to a lifetime of poverty,
which is what the other
side wants to see happen.
- What kind of pushback
did you get on that?
I mean, I'm guessing
the teacher's union
and Randi Weingarten,
all of them,
they probably put in a ton
of money to stop this thing,
but it happened.
- You know, I spent two
years on the campaign trail
here in Arkansas talking
about what we were going to do
in terms of education reform.
I made no secret that it
was my number one priority.
And I won with a historic margin
and for a first time
candidate here in the state,
and felt like that was because
my message was resonating,
and that was the people
overwhelmingly coming out
and saying that this was
what they wanted to see.
And there was
tremendous support.
And so, we went out
and we acted on it.
Could not have done it
without amazing partners
in our legislature.
Certainly, there were some
people that pushed back.
But as my dad likes to say,
just because some people
eat their soup louder
doesn't mean it taste better.
Just because there are
a handful of people
that are yelling and screaming,
one, it doesn't
mean they're right,
and two, it doesn't mean that
they speak for the masses
'cause that's certainly not
the case here in Arkansas.
- Do you think the Republicans
have had a branding problem
over the last couple of years?
You know, if you
look at the midterms,
everyone said it was
gonna be a red wave.
It obviously didn't
turn out to be.
And it seemed that people
were sort of fed up
with the Democrats,
but they still didn't
wanna vote Republican
to some degree, at least
at a national level,
even though the
Republicans got the House,
but there clearly wasn't a wave.
Is there something that
can be done on that,
if you agree with me.
- Absolutely.
I think we, as I was
saying a few minutes ago,
I think we have
to go on offense.
So often, Republicans
are so afraid to lean in
and take the offensive position.
And we sort of apologize many
times for being conservative.
And we shouldn't allow the left
to, one, define
us or demonize us.
And we have allowed
that for far too long.
We have to stand up
and start pushing back.
Whether people like him or not,
one of the things that Donald
Trump did so successfully
was he gave Republicans
and conservatives
a microphone and a platform
to start pushing back and say,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
we're not the bad guys here.
We're not on the side of crazy.
That's the other side.
And what they're selling
is frankly just not true.
He challenged every major
institution in the country,
whether it was the media,
big tech, higher ed,
and started pushing back.
And we're seeing a lot more
Republicans start to do that.
And I think when we do and
we go on offense, we win.
- To that point, you actually
gave the Republican response
to the State of the Union.
And I thought it was
really excellent.
I thought it was a positive
vision, the type of thing that,
well, it's really what
you're saying right there.
There was sort of,
like, we need to use government
effectively when we can.
But that doesn't seem to me
to be where all Republicans
are at at the moment.
You know, if you listen to
Mike Pence or Chris Christie
on some of the stuff
with DeSantis in Florida,
that suddenly government
shouldn't do anything
even when it's to level
the playing field.
So there's still work
that has to be done there.
- Absolutely, I think
there's still work.
I think your opinion
though is the right one,
that my message is
the good one here.
No, I'm just kidding.
(Dave and Sarah laughing)
I like your take.
- We're going, okay, good.
- I think we should wrap here
that you said I did a great job
and I had the right messaging.
Only kidding.
- That's it.
But I do think we have to
draw very clear contrast
with the other side,
but we don't have to do it
in a way that is so negative.
I'm not a glass is half
empty type of person.
And so, I want to see
the best in people.
And I still think, regardless
of some of the bad things
that are happening
around our country,
that America's still
the greatest country
that the world has ever known,
and we shouldn't forget that.
We have to lean into that
message while at the same time
drawing a contrast
with the other side.
That's not negative,
that's simply defining
who they are versus
what we believe in.
And I think we have to do
that in order to be effective.
- So one of the things I'm
always trying to do here,
and it's getting
harder and harder,
is I really am trying to
sit down with Democrats
when possible.
We're getting pretty
much no responses.
These days, we just get ignored.
But I'm gonna guess,
maybe I'm wrong,
that a Democrat in Arkansas
is probably not as radical
as what we're seeing out
of most of the Democrats
in mainstream
media or out of DC.
Is that fair to say?
- Certainly, we've got a
few that are a little bit
on the very far left end.
However, we had some
great partnership
with Democrat legislators here,
where we were able
to work together
on a few pieces of legislation
over this first session
and had great success.
So certainly, I think
there's a greater sense
of cooperation and
collaboration on the state level
than you're gonna
find in Washington.
Washington has
gotten so polarized
that they've become
completely paralyzed.
And it's hard to expect
or see anything meaningful
coming from there.
But I think on the state level,
you'll find that
there are some moments
where Democrats and
Republicans can work together.
- Do you miss anything about
the DC situation and just the,
there's a certain amount of
energy that comes with it,
either good, or bad, or both.
- I definitely miss the people.
I got to work with, like I said,
some of the most amazing,
talented individuals
I've ever encountered.
And I loved my time there.
I loved the people that I got
to be in the trenches with.
And so, I certainly
miss that aspect of it.
I don't miss the nastiness
and the craziness
of the Washington
press corps though.
I'm happy to be away from that.
- Right.
What else is going
on in Arkansas
that you're pushing,
trying to lead on
that we should know about?
- You know, some of
the biggest things
that we have really
spent our time on,
we went into this first session
with four big priorities,
education being
first and foremost,
and passed what we think
is the most comprehensive,
historic education package,
certainly in the
state of Arkansas,
but probably across the country.
We spend a lot of time
on workforce development,
early childhood literacy,
things that really
lay a foundation
for an individual's
lifetime of success.
We've cracked down on
violent repeat offenders.
That was our second
big priority,
was a safer, stronger Arkansas.
We passed legislation that
actually put harsh penalties
on drug dealers, specifically
those trafficking heroin
that caused overdoses,
creating truth in sentencing.
So if somebody gets
sentenced to 20 years,
we're actually gonna
make you serve 20 years,
which unfortunately
was not the case here
and not the case
in a lot of places
across the state of Arkansas.
Our third big priority was
cutting the state income tax.
We've got Texas and
Tennessee on each side of us
who have no state income tax.
In order for us to
continue to be competitive,
we had to work to
start chipping away
at Arkansas's income tax.
And we made significant
progress on that front.
And very proud that we
were able to pass education
and criminal justice reform,
at the same time, passing
savings back onto the taxpayers.
The last thing we wanted to do
was really promote
the natural state.
That's the nickname and the
motto for the state of Arkansas
because we have an absolutely
beautiful landscape
and wanna go out and promote
Arkansas's outdoor economy
and really bring
people into our state
to enjoy the incredible natural
amenities that we have here.
And so, those were
the four big key areas
that we focused on.
Got something accomplished
in all four of those
and made what we think
is just an incredibly
successful first session.
The other area that
unfortunately we had to spend
a lot of time on over
the last several weeks,
Arkansas was hit by
devastating tornadoes
that came through our state.
It hit directly here
in Central Arkansas,
as well as a small town, Wynne,
over in the eastern
part of our state.
And we've been in the recovery
and rebuilding process of that.
We have a long road to go,
but very proud of the
way that Arkansans
have stepped up and really
taken care of each other
over the last several weeks.
- Are you getting the help
from FEMA that you need
or at least that you requested?
- Oh, we actually have.
I have to say this is
one of the few areas
where the federal government
has really stepped up.
And we're very appreciative
of their willingness to help
and how quick they
have been to respond
in providing assistance
that we've requested.
- Let's back up to the tax one.
You said cutting
state tax obviously
because you got no income
tax states on your borders.
You know, I was in Cali
and now I'm in Florida,
and I did not move here
for the no tax situation,
but it has been quite nice.
I mean, how does that
work when you go in
and try to cut that tax when
you are a state that has taxes,
like, nobody that is
working for the state
is happy with you.
They wanna keep their jobs,
but it obviously is gonna
help you build the economy.
- Well, we have to look at ways
that we can make government
more efficient and
modernize government.
And there are a lot of places
where we have duplicate programs
and we have to eliminate
some of that waste.
And when we do actually
pass it onto the taxpayer,
so often, even
conservative Republicans
will eliminate government waste,
but then they just add
it into another program.
We're trying to make sure
that we actually pass
that savings on in
the form of tax cuts.
We were successful in
doing that this session.
And I'm hopeful that we can
continue on that trajectory
and keep chipping away
at our state's income tax
until we're able to
completely phase it out.
It's not gonna happen overnight
and we wanna be
responsible in the process,
but it's a goal I think
we have to work towards.
- Are you telling me
you could cut taxes,
and your roads won't
automatically collapse,
and you'll still be
able to pay for school
and other stuff,
'cause that's wild.
- Yeah, not only were we
able to pay for schools,
but we were able to make
the largest investment
into our schools,
our public schools,
and education reform in
the history of our state,
in modern history that is.
And so, very proud of the fact
that we were able to get
those things accomplished
and still cut taxes
here in the state.
- On the criminal justice
stuff that you mentioned
and the sentencing,
things of that nature,
do you get pushback
on those things?
I would imagine in
a mostly red state,
people are kind of
on board that, right?
- Absolutely, we've seen
overwhelming support
for people coming out.
Nobody wants to live in a
community that isn't safe.
And so, locking up
violent repeat offenders
is rarely going to be something
that is pushed back against,
unless you're part of
the crazy radical left,
then you think it's a great idea
to let those people back
out onto the streets.
But here in Arkansas, that's
certainly not the case.
- Right.
This is a bit of a non-sequitur,
but does Bill ever
come back down there?
Is he welcomed in
Arkansas at this point?
- You know, he's still fairly
well-liked here in Arkansas.
The Clinton Presidential Library
is based in our capital
city in Little Rock.
And he comes back from
time to time for that.
And, you know, we see him
here very occasionally.
Hillary, on the other hand,
not quite so welcome
back in Arkansas.
I think a lot of people feel
like she abandoned the state.
And most people I think
are pretty okay with that.
I would say Bill Clinton though
is still fairly well-liked
and well-remembered here
in the state of Arkansas.
- So I have to say, as
we wrap up, governor,
when I was watching
the rebuttal,
I really was thinking,
man, she should be running.
I know you've got
a new gig here,
but we are rolling
into a big 2024 thing.
The fighting has already begun.
It's already starting
to get nutty.
Do you have any of
those aspirations?
Obviously, your dad ran
for president twice,
if I'm not mistaken, right?
And then the first
time, pretty close.
Does any of that appeal to
you in any way whatsoever?
- I've done my
time in Washington,
very happy to be
back home in Arkansas
where life is a little easier
and certainly the people
are much friendlier.
So very happy to be home.
And I'll leave the
fighting and the 2024
and all that craziness to
the other folks out there.
I'm gonna keep my
focus here on our state
and how we can
really impact change
and help the people of Arkansas.
- Final sales pitch
for the people
that are considering
moving or taking vacation.
Coming up, why should
they go to Arkansas?
- You'll find no better place
than the state of Arkansas
to either live or to visit.
Certainly, we would
love you to live here.
I've heard they've got an
amazing governor there.
If you don't believe me, you
should come try it yourself.
But we have a really
special place,
amazing people,
beautiful scenery.
And we hope that people
will come here and visit
and decide that they wanna
stay and live here too.
- Well, governor, I have
only been to Arkansas once,
believe it or not.
I did one night there while
on tour about five years ago.
So I owe a trip and I hope
to get to see you in person.
- Absolutely, we'd be
happy to host you anytime.
- All right, Governor
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
thanks so much.
- You bet.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.